tenemos aquí la ecuación de una parábola
y el objetivo de este vídeo es ver otra
forma de encontrar el foco y la
directriz de una parábola
si tenemos su ecuación y bueno si lo que
tengo es esta ecuación lo primero que se
me ocurre es dejar a la insólita aunque
hay pasar este menos 23 cuartos del otro
lado del igual porque no sé mi cerebro
funciona mejor si está todo simplificado
entonces vamos a sumar 23 cuartos de los
dos lados y nos queda ya menos 23
cuartos más 23 cuartos se cancela
entonces ye igual a menos un tercio de x
menos 1 al cuadrado más 23 cuartos
y ahora vamos a repasar lo que hemos
visto acerca de los focos y las
directrices digamos que tenemos un foco
en el punto y coma
y que tenemos una directriz directriz
una directriz completamente horizontal
descrita por la fórmula ye igual acá lo
que hemos visto en los vídeos pasados es
que si tenemos a cualquier poco ya una
directriz de esta forma entonces la
fórmula de la parábola es de la forma y
igual a 1 entre 2 x b - k ver - k por x
menos a al cuadrado nada se ve más k
entre 2 y como puedes observar
fácilmente este término este término de
aquí corresponde a este término de acá y
también este término de aquí este
coeficiente de este binomio corresponde
a este término de acá
y finalmente esta constante corresponde
a esta constante de acá y de hecho
podemos utilizar esta información para
encontrar el foco y la directriz de la
parábola que se define con esta ecuación
aquí inmediatamente ya tenemos uno de
los valores porque aquí tenemos x menos
1 que corresponde a x menos a entonces
sabemos directamente que a tiene que ser
igual a 1
y bueno para encontrar b y acá tenemos
dos formas una la más común sería tratar
de encontrar a b ya que utilizando
álgebra directamente sin pensar en lo
que hay de fondo lo que hay pero es
bastante sencillo
este término de aquí menos un tercio
corresponde a este término de aquí 1
entre 2 x b menos acá y eso nos da una
ecuación de la cual podemos obtener el
valor de menos acá por otro lado esta
constante 23 4
tiene que ser igual además acá sobre dos
y entonces ya podemos obtener los
valores de b y de acá porque tenemos dos
ecuaciones distintas y 25 gritas
entonces solo tenemos que resolver este
sistema de ecuaciones y obtenemos a ver
ya acá y listo sin embargo lo que vamos
a hacer en este vídeo es usar todo lo
que sabemos acerca de los pocos y las
directrices y las parábolas aunque hay
bueno así es que vamos a empezar por
encontrar el vértice de esta parábola el
vértice es a ver estamos considerando
dos tipos de parábolas las que abren
hacia arriba y entonces su vértice es el
mínimo el punto mínimo de esta curva o
las parábolas que abren hacia abajo y
entonces su vértice es el punto máximo
también hay unas palabras que están
moldeadas pero esas no las estamos
viendo ahorita y su ecuación tiene más
términos que no estamos viendo aquí pero
bueno eso lo veremos más adelante por el
momento sólo tenemos parábolas que abren
hacia arriba
o hacia abajo y esta parábola es una de
esas parábolas que se abren hacia abajo
porque aquí tenemos una constante este
término siempre es positivo y se hace
cada vez más grande pero este
coeficiente es un coeficiente negativo
entonces conforme la x se aleja se va
yendo cada vez más hacia abajo así es
que el vértice es el máximo de esta
ecuación y por lo tanto se obtiene
cuando este binomio es igual a cero ok
porque así no le estamos gastando nada y
tenemos el mayor valor posible aunque
entonces voy a borrar esto
así es que el vértice
vértice lo obtenemos cuando x es igual a
entonces el vértice tiene en la
coordenada x 11 y en ese valor de x que
es igual a 23 cuartos 23 cuartos de
hecho es igual a 53 cuartos
este es el vértice de la parábola y es
una parábola que se abre hacia abajo voy
a empezar a graficar tenemos aquí el eje
de las sedes
y tenemos aquí
el eje de las x eje de las tres ejes de
las x digamos que por aquí está el uno
por aquí está el 2
tenemos nuestro vértice en el uno con
cinco y tres cuartos o sea casi seis por
aquí tenemos que enumerar por lo menos
hasta 7 12
el vértice está más o menos por aquí uno
con cinco y tres cuartos y la parábola
se ve más o menos así
aunque es una parábola que se abre hacia
abajo porque este coeficiente de aquí es
negativo y bueno dibuje esta parábola a
mano en lugar de computadora por lo cual
no es muy exacta pero no necesitamos más
ahora por el momento no tenemos mucha
información acerca de esta parábola pero
nos gustaría saber cuál es su foco y
cuál es su directriz sabemos que el foco
va a estar en algún punto de esta recta
va a tener la misma coordenada x que el
vértice esta recta es la recta x igual a
1 entonces digamos por ejemplo que el
vértice está aquí si el vértice está
aquí eso significa que la directriz va a
ser una línea por acá
más o menos y todavía no encontramos la
directriz ni el foco nada más los
estamos dibujando para tener una buena
idea de más o menos dónde están pero
como el vértice es parte de la parábola
entonces esta distancia de aquí tiene
que ser igual a esta distancia de acá
aunque hay porque cualquier punto de la
parábola incluyendo al vértice equidista
de la directriz y del foco pero bueno
este foco es el punto
y esta línea de aquí es la directriz que
se define por la ecuación de igual acá
que entonces queremos saber cuál es esta
distancia de aquí del vértice a la
directriz y para obtenerla podemos
observar que la directriz está arriba
del foco entonces esta distancia es acá
- ve que está acá y menos la altura del
foco sin embargo esto no siempre
funciona por ejemplo si el foco está
arriba de la directriz tendríamos que
poner de menos acá para que fuera un
valor positivo pero lo que siempre
funciona es tomar el valor absoluto
db - acá y queremos conocer esta
distancia porque a partir del vértice
con esta distancia podemos encontrar
súper fácil el foco y la altura de la
directriz
entonces nos interesa mucho saber cuánto
vale esto pero eso es algo que si
podemos encontrar porque aquí tenemos la
ecuación de la parábola y aquí tenemos
la fórmula de la parábola en la cual
tenemos el término de menos acá aquí en
el coeficiente del binomio b x al
cuadrado entonces este coeficiente tiene
que ser igual a este coeficiente y de
esa forma vamos a obtener cuánto vale de
menos acá que hay de hecho vamos a
ponerlo por aquí sabemos que menos un
tercio tiene que ser igual a uno entre
dos por ver - acá uno entre dos por ver
menos acá aunque vamos a poner este
menos un tercio en amarillo menos uno
tercio y para resolver esta ecuación
donde lo que más nos interesa es obtener
el valor de v - que todo junto podemos
tomar el recíproco entonces nos queda
menos 3 igual a 2 por ver - k 2 por b
menos acá y después dividimos entre 2 y
nos queda b menos que igual a menos 3
entre 2 y listo
entonces si tomamos el valor absoluto bb
menos que lo que nos queda es 3 medios k
menos de es igual también a 3 medios
medios que obtuvimos esta distancia de
aquí que es el valor absoluto de b menos
que a partir de estos coeficientes de
aquí estos dos coeficientes tienen que
ser iguales y a partir de esa igualdad
obtenemos b menos que su valor absoluto
es la distancia del foco a la directriz
así es que esta distancia de aquí
tres medios y bueno en realidad queremos
tomar la mitad de esa distancia porque
justo a la mitad entre el foco y la
directriz se encuentra el vértice y ya
tenemos la localización exacta del
vértice entonces para obtener el foco lo
único que necesitamos hacer es tomar el
vértice y restarle la mitad de esta
distancia y para obtener la altura de la
directriz tomamos la altura del vértice
y le sumamos la mitad de esta distancia
y bueno la mitad de esta distancia es un
medio por tres medios o sea tres cuartos
así es que empecemos con la directriz la
directriz es la recta ye igual tenemos
aquí que el vértice está a una altura de
23 cuartos o sea que empezamos con 23
cuartos
a esta altura más
más la mitad de esta distancia que yo
sea más
cuartos más tres cuartos o sea
veintiséis cuartos que es igual a 6.5
así es que la directriz es la recta ye
igual a 6.5 creer y aquí está el 6.5
pero ahora vamos con el foco ok por un
lado sabemos que su coordenada en x es
igual a 1 y su coordenada y su altura es
igual a la altura del vértice o sea 23
cuartos menos la mitad de esta distancia
o sea menos tres cuartos y 23 4 - tres
cuartos es simplemente 20 cuartos
veinte cuartos es simplemente un 5 bueno
entonces ya terminamos el foco es el
punto 15 y la directriz es la recta y
igual a 6.5